Iran is lashing out at the US over new
financial pressure saying there will be
no diplomatic end to the standoff this
morning Iranian president Hassan rouhani
called new US sanctions outrageous and
idiotic his words 'no spokesman for
iran's Foreign Ministry said that
measures equal a permanent closure for
diplomacy after Iran shot down a US
drone last week president trim' trump
signed an executive order yesterday
targeting Iran's supreme leader for the
first time the sanctions block access to
the international financial system Ben
Tracy is at the White House Ben Iran's
president really laid in to mr. Trump he
certainly did not hold back in an
offensive choice of words he said that
the White House is quote afflicted by
mental retardation and he mocked
President Trump for simultaneously
requesting talks and imposing sanctions
so if the strategy here is to use
sanctions to force Iran in the
negotiating table so far it's not
working who knows what's going to happen
I can only tell you we cannot ever let
Iran have a nuclear weapon instead of
using force President Trump put on a
show of it in the Oval Office signing
the sanctions order in front of the
cameras flanked by his vice president
and Treasury secretary the sanctions
targeting Ron's supreme leader in at
least eight Iranian military commanders
including the official the u.s. believes
is responsible for shooting down an
American drone last week
ago she we would love to be able to
negotiated you if they want to if they
don't want to that's fine too
the US has imposed nearly one thousand
specific sanctions on Iran since pulling
out of the nuclear deal and they are
taking a toll on its economy the value
of Iran's currency has dropped 60
percent in inflation is more than 40
percent you cannot start a dialogue with
somebody who is threatening you who is
intimidating you on Monday iran's
ambassador to the UN said tensions
between the two countries is quote
really dangerous instead of negotiating
Iran is retaliating allegedly attacking
tankers in the Persian Gulf shooting
down the American drone and threatening
to enrich more uranium the fuel that can
be used to make nuclear bombs what
they've sought to do is to try to turn
up the heat to see if the president will
respond and to see what they can in fact
get away with President Trump warns that
if he does change his approach he does
not need congressional approval for a
strike I do like keeping them abreast
but I don't have to do it illegally now
the president says he still wants to
talk to Iran's leaders and the only
precondition is that they cannot have
nuclear weapons
of course the nuclear deal the president
pulled out of last year was designed to
prevent just that Anthony Ben Iran will
be a prime topic at the g20 summit later
this week what should we expect well you
can expect a lot of US allies to raise
questions about this strategy so far
they are not on board with these
sanctions and the Russians are also
getting involved now too they say they
have intelligence that shows that US
drone was in Iranian airspace when it
was shot down last week
Anthony Ben thank you